I want to show you a couple of things
on Joe and some of the things that I've
been working on now,
like I mentioned the door,
my whole,
my main direction in Jujitsu is always
been to major Jitsu better in MMA,
in the UFC.
The UFC is what got me into
Jujitsu when I felt you have seals.
That was the most amazing thing ever.
And then,
you know,
immediately I started doing Jujitsu.
Quite is my favorite fighter.
Anybody who did anything,
what you did.
So I was going from always been,
oh and then like it's funny because you,
and one way some,
a lot of people in that
community see you as a bed.
Why did you see how the Guy Stopped?
[inaudible] has got
against us but I don't see,
I never saw that too.
I always felt like you trying to create
your own routines and others trying to
help to Jensen and that's all it was,
is I,
I,
I got,
uh,
I got tired of seeing like in UFC 13,
15,
17 tired of seeing Jujitsu guys just,
you know,
um,
when Jerry Bolander Font,
uh,
five years your shout,
I was like,
oh,
how was he?
How he was getting beat up when,
uh,
what had been eight,
I fought Matt Hughes.
Man,
that hurts so much because Jujitsu
was my life and I thought we got to do
something to fix this,
especially in the car.
Let me,
let me,
let me show you a little bit.
There's no,
the one thing,
pride too.
I saw him,
I saw him the just pulled
on like this for a second.
And that's when I thought,
Ooh,
that could be something there.
Because generally,
you know,
people would be,
you'd be quick.
You guys were doing like this
when there was headbutts right?
And then it headbutts came out.
So this became a good way to
survive from the punishment.
So from there,
um,
when I saw him some do this and hold,
I decided to start bringing it
all up and really get use my legs.
How?
Because with the key,
it's easy to control here,
control the posture,
but hard to control the posh and
your legs keep slipping down.
You want to go high guard.
So my,
my host,
my host system started
becoming this kind of stuff.
Like there's no way he
could touch my face here.
There's no way.
And I see chrome again,
Shinier EOP.
So,
and even Marcello sometimes
he comes here to hold,
you know,
to hold up man.
So the rubber guard,
I don't know if you heard that,
but it's all about just
getting into this position.
If his arms up here is awful care,
I'll attack this on,
I'll even go like this and there's no
way he can hit me and there's no way,
um,
uh,
he can pull out and stand up again.
So that became my obsession is to develop
a guard where they can't get up and
run away and being able to prevent him.
You can't elbow me right here.
Soon as I cross both these legs,
there's no way you can help me.
Is it possible?
So,
um,
that's,
that's what I developed
in those for Jujitsu.
And like you said,
the judge would come here and do,
a lot of them took that as,
oh,
he thinks he knows more than us.
Look at him,
he's turning his back on due dates.
And the reason I dropped the Guid is
cause I felt that every second you grabbed
the call and grab the sleeve,
that's not the same fighting stance MMA.
So I thought,
you know,
let's look,
I didn't drop the game
to say fuck you Jujitsu.
It was a,
you know what for Nma,
the gives them how good we have to,
the fighting stance has to be the same.
When we trap,
when we train grappling with
no punches or with punches,
it has to be the same stance,
the same final stance.
So based on what,
again,
when I saw you and hence or doing it had
to come from that defensive posture and
their old book so you don't get hit.
Then the legs come up.
Then you started talking while you
control them while you keep them from
standing up and go and stand up again.
Because there was a fight with
Fabiana [inaudible] and Dave Fernanda,
UFC,
UFC 20 something.
We're Fabiana,
he had a good arm bar from the
guard so he fights day for night.
He was a pretty good
rustler Fabiana he had,
could not take him down.
So they get against the
cage and Fabiano here,
which are full guard,
pulled him into his garb and then put the
feet on the hips and two to set up for
the arm bar.
Cause that's how he does it.
And then Dave and I just
stood up and just walked away,
do it again.
So then Fabiana here gets up,
he did it five times in that fight.
He jumps garden,
pulls him down.
But as soon as he opened up his
legs and put his feet on the hips,
Dave Linn ever just to do
it again and it gave him,
and I ended up winning.
So for me,
I was like,
that's a problem because
they don't have to be on top.
If you pull guard because
you can't take the fire down.
He doesn't have to stay there.
As soon as you opened the guard,
you're going to get up
just like a Allister over.
And when he fought five,
five,
you Superdome [inaudible]
pulled them in his guard.
But as soon as he opened it,
Alister said,
come on,
I'm not going to go down there.
So it became a,
okay,
that's a problem.
We're going to have to
have them in the guard.
If we can't wrestle low,
we have to pull guard and then
keep them from standing up.
So the clinch became,
in my opinion,
the most important thing,
cause you've gotta be able to
coach him and not only him,
so they don't stand up but conscience.
So they don't hit you.
And then you have to hop off
offense from that clench.
So anytime someone would train the
key and have the call in the sleep,
that's not working on the club quarters.
So that's like you're not working on it.
So that's why we're seeing all these
black Delsi come in five or after fighting
or all these guys,
American talking black,
the black man,
and then when they're on their back,
they're not used to
offense from the defense.
The best defense of position it.
They just don't ever work there.
They think,
okay,
I'm just going to train your game,
grabbed the call and grab the sleeve and
then it's going to somehow work itself
out somehow.
It's going to work itself out
when it doesn't work like that.
Like if,
if you're practicing,
you're fighting stance like this,
but in a fight you have to go here,
it's going to be different.
You should have been
practicing like of course.
Of course.
That was my philosophy and
everything I've ever done,
every,
every little tweak I'd ever done.
Did you Dentsu some people in the Jiu
Jitsu community got me and he goes,
number one guy,
he thinks that I'm doing it just to
think that I'm the best guy and that I'm
better than Jujitsu.
Keep that.
Always look.
He dropped the key.
He hits you gypsy.
He's betraying and like
it's not about that.
He even calls you,
I'm talking.
He said [inaudible],
what's he doing?
He's taken off the guy.
You gave him a black down here.
Cause I said if I ever teach Jujitsu,
I'm going to teach without the
gate just to do my part for MMA.
You can keep the gate and you can train
that you need to do the mood in the
house.
But some I need to focus and
dedicate myself to try and to try.
I'm trying to approve Jujitsu and MMA.
That's all I was ever tried for Jujitsu,
not for Samba and not pro wrestling.
I'm for striking.
I'm Jujitsu,
pure blood,
pure blood.
And so that is the misconception that
it has it around and they're saying,
oh,
he's changing names.
He's,
he's taking moves and changing the names.
Look,
that's the rest of the move to twister.
He calls it the twister.
It's actually the,
the wrestlers guillotine and well I didn't
change the mood Hicken and John John
Changed it because I
would come in and I say,
this is a guilty I learned in
wrestling and they were like,
there was already a killer team.
That's the front headlock.
That's a good,
so they started calling it twister.
I don't know.
It's not the twister.
So then later people started saying,
look,
he changes a wrestling
move and he's a fraud.
He's taken moves and changing them and
he's making all these new facilities
positions and changing.
Then the only names that I invent,
like the names that I came up with were
moves or transitions that didn't have
names.
So in my,
in my brain,
I can teach better and I could
learn better than every transition,
every position,
not even if it's a submission.
Every transition,
every set up has a name so
that I could with my students,
I can get on the phone and we have a
language that we're talking to them.
Oh.
Otherwise if you're on the phone,
you're going,
you know that one,
who would he put your hand on hip
and like what mood you have to show,
you have to show that.
Like,
I don't know.
So for me,
Americans like naming everything.
So that's what,
that's what the naming process came in.
I came up with all these crazy names,
these stupid names because it
was not until he came back down.
And then my goal is to
pull my form over here.
Now there's more pressure now,
right here,
very hard to do anything.
And um,
the next step was to come
here and then hug right here.
And then if you're going
to punch with this here,
I'm going to be ready already and I'm
already holding the foot and I can control
right here,
very hard to do anything.
And then I'm right here.
This is where I'm at.
You need flexibility.
And then if you join to
stand up with this leg,
I went to figure four here
and then right here it's over.
You'd be very hard.
You feel that,
so that,
so that is a way to make it so that
you're defensive and they can't punch you.
And um,
I'm actually going for the kill.
I'm not being defensive.
I'm going for the Co.
And in my experience,
the bigger the government wants 60,
the bigger the guy is.
If he's won 85,
one 90,
and he's a wrestler.
In my experience,
the only thing that works is to get here
in time and hug that I'm right here.
This is an old hot right
cause we've very hard for,
for anybody to do it.
Then once this book comes
over here and then here,
very hard really to do anything there.
That's the goal.
And it's really not that hard.
I played this game against my Tufts
students on the day on a daily basis.
So the best thing for you to do is
keep both your hands on the chest,
both of them.
And then yes,
that's that's cause now you have an
opportunity to maybe posture you do.
So what I want to do
and leave you these fan,
now you can't punch me and now you can't
posture because you only can do it with
one heart.
They understand.
And then once I grabbed the
other leg here and clear here,
very hard,
you can't punch and then I
can attack this on her hair.
I'm looking at this one.
I could take this arm this way
or I could just right here.
You can't defend with your right arm
because I've already tracked it and then
we're here.
This is my,
one of my go to arm ourselves and then
if it all fails and a lot of times we
just ended up here.
Then we had the finding from here,
like you survived everything
and then now we're here.
I'm looking to come back to hook here.
I'm looking to come back to the
cure and take this or you roll.
And then this week,
because a lot of times it got one
guy will get there and he's like,
fuck that.
I'm just going to roll.
And then at the sweep and I go up and I
roll it too and I pass your guard at the
same time with that role.
But that's the last resort I'm trying to
grab to the neck that our first connect
the arm,
keep control in the way.
How on the next year I'm going to,
I'm going to go after their arm or putting
my foot over and hold onto your hat.
What a joke.
Oh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to try to get
this aren't on the bat.
If I can't get off the island on the mat,
then there's a different
things I can do here.
I can try to clear the neck anyways.
I been try to clear them.
If I can't clear the night,
then we can just stay here and then I
could punch here until yet they're going
[inaudible] yeah,
well he could stall it out.
People could smell some news.
They always didn't want to stay.
Especially now they want to stay here.
Yes.
So he did the recipes come
from the butcher heater's fine.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Miss it.
This,
this comes from,
this is a patient,
a patient game.
So that's why I can still work
from here and I could still,
what I would do another may as punch
here until you and then Google.
Now we're here.
Right?
So,
but the most important thing is to get
that hand on the map before the Lex come
up.
So anytime you're here
and I have the under hook,
that means whether I'm here or here,
that means all I got to do is bring this
up here and now that arm is right out
of the mix.
So when I'm rolling,
I'm always looking for that overlook.
Always.
As soon as I get this Oprah hook here,
boom.
These lectures that come in here,
they're going to be right here and then
fam right here and then because this
art,
so it's all come from the overall.
Even from butterfly card here,
if I'm here and butterfly guard,
all I got to do is release
and now I'm here and then,
and then there's a stacking.
You have to be patient.
Nothing's quick.
Am I fail?
You might pull out of it,
but then we go back to it again.
I was,
you know,
some guys pull out of sweaty.
It was just like a,
you're trying to take him down.
You didn't take him down.
You set it up again.
Trying to think to like where Joe,
it takes me four times to
get him in his own polite.
He's seen so much wrong.
He'll pull out and then
we have started again.
Boom.
He smashed me and then he pulls out
and let me start again and then boom,
like on the fourth one,
boom,
I caught him.
He puts on,
you don't have to bat,
so it's just like take down.
If you keep trying to take
a guy down and meanwhile,
even though it's failing,
you can't get hit because the way to
defendant is the stack stay tight and not
do anything.
The way to stop it,
it's don't punch because as soon as you
punch a mess at Max me out at one point,
your hands already on the map.
Boom.
The best analogy that you've ever made
about it is when you talked about head
kicks.
Like if you tried to teach
someone how to throw a head kick,
know I can't fucking kicks him out,
man.
How am I going to kick some of that?
But you're getting a guy who was like,
Maury Smith a great kickboxer.
It's easy,
but then it kicks them in because
they've done it so many times.
It becomes a part of
their natural movement.
Once you develop the type
of guard that he has,
I tell everybody,
if you don't roll with him,
you don't understand what's possible.
Once you roll with him,
his legs are like arms and they're moving
in positions that you don't come to
expect a normal training
and until you experience it,
you don't know the possibilities.
I think that's the next level of MMA.
I think what he's doing
right now is going to be,
you know,
we're seeing all these new like wheel
kicks and new techniques and it's
striking.
That's the next thing
is his car techniques.
I really believe it all started
from watching Hanzo diversity.
That's all.
They're like,
Ooh
cause I was a high guard
player with the key.
No key,
the legs keep slipping
the let's leave some.
So it's hard to attack.
So then we're like,
Oh let's just keep the leg up here.
He's the,
the necessity to keep the light
glows and that matter is a really,
is it really effective?
Uh,
but again,
if the guy try to be defensive,
uh,
is hard for you I believe.
I believe you had combine some kinds
of strikes,
some kind of punishment.
Yes.
Your fee.
We've was maybe to create
that kind of panic.
The show is the best day in day out
of those positions without struck.
So I was here,
I love the shoulder here.
I'm holding
this position right here.
If you could,
maybe I'll do it on Joe,
but if you could see this right here.
Again this is all you're going to keep it.
You're not going to let me have the arm
bar cause as soon as you straighten that
it's going to be tight.
So all I'm going to do is just throw
elbows rammed the perfect angle to come
down this anchor Russia
that's published and setting
up the arm bar and listen.
Very common and my,
and my style I have getting here,
I'm keeping this tight.
See this position right?
I call this muddy waters here and he
can't do anything and I have full away on
his elbow and the pump.
Take the arm.
This arm is out of Mexico.
This is tight.
So this is a position
I worked to get into.
This could take three minutes to get into,
but once I'm here it's over
now and slowly bit by bit.
I have to move this elbow and
cause how do you move that boy?
It's very hard.
I can't move into here.
Pop so hard.
He has good posture.
So why?
So what I need to do is to
get my form on this side,
cross my here I'm looking
at how I squeeze the elbows,
see how it's easier and then
I go back to this and that.
Here,
this is my on one move that I do all
the time and then once I'm here I don't
even need to bring the leg over the face.
I could just finish it right here.
If he has flexible arms then we take,
if I don't want to take a chance,
I know this way.
So interesting.
That's stuff that I
would love to show crop.
I would love to cause he's
already trying to do it.
He's already flexible.
I think that would be very
valuable in all my guys do this.
This is standard stuff that all,
I got some guys that are doing amazing.
Anytime I'm in the car,
the lights come up and
guys already in trouble.
She Aoki,
he got,
he's the one who uses it the most.
If you watch New York,
he just a very hot,
basic version of this.
I was in 2000 I was in
Japan in 2005 and um,
I showed off stuff.
He never seen it before.
Immediately starts
using it and his fights,
he starts trying on everybody.
And so just something that
I would love to show chrome,
I would love to.
I think I might be able just
in case he's in a bad spot,
if I the lesser of the
two on top of them might,
it might be an extra weapon that
made it a gay Wacko is good.
Yes.
When we go to [inaudible],
thank you very much for your
patience and thanks for your input.
I'm going to spend to come.
They're going to slip on it.
Thank you.
Also can estimate this again like.